in the midst of the coalescing and
embolden of white supremacy the likes of
which we've not seen for a very long
time in the United States FoxNews
propagandist Tucker Carlson is now
claiming that white supremacy fears are
simply a hoax now I don't know if he
means the idea that white supremacy
exists in the United States is a hoax
like is he saying there's not really
white supremacy or is he saying white
supremacy is real but we shouldn't fear
it it's not totally clear but let's take
a look at what Tucker had to say but the
whole thing is a lie if you were to
assemble a list a hierarchy of concerns
of problems this country faces where
would white supremecy be on the list
right up there with Russia probably it's
actually not a real problem in America
the combined membership of every white
supremacist organization in this country
with able to fit inside a college
football stadium I mean seriously this
is a country where the average person is
getting poorer where the suicide rate is
spiking white supremacy that's the
problem this is a hoax
just like the Russia hoax it's a
conspiracy theory used to divide the
country and keep a hold on power that's
exactly what's going on so this is
actually this is a combination of what
about ISM and straw men which are
related but not exactly the same Tucker
first talks about the membership of
white supremacist organizations that's
not how it works today okay membership
organizations with tote bags and logos
and membership cards are just not the
way modern white nationalism and white
supremacy are spreading and in fact on
yesterday's show I interviewed former
neo-nazi Frank mink and he told us when
he was in the movement when he was in
the Klan in the 90s it was about
community it was about in-person
meetings it was about real world
interaction in 2019 because of the
internet and social media that is simply
not the way that white supremacy and
white nationalism are spreading it
doesn't matter that you're not in a
official in an official group like when
he was in the Klan with the rallies and
meetings and cookouts and all of that
stuff resembling a more formal
membership by definition it is now
radicalization that is happening to
people primarily through media and they
can be anywhere this is a total
distraction
well how many people are actually
members of defined and named white
supremacist organizations it's a
ridiculous straw man and then Tucker
says we shouldn't be concerned about
white supremacy based on the number of
people who are members of these groups
I wonder then if he would also say we
don't have to be worried about anti feh
because the truth is that an Tifa a
group that I have never defended is such
a tiny group that it barely exists as an
organized institution and yet Fox News
and right-wing media won't stop talking
about an Tifa who has an tyfa killed and
then consider the el paso shooter Dylann
roof charlottesville and on and on and
on when you actually look at the data
depending on which organization's report
you look at seventy to ninety eight
percent of political violence in the
United States recently is right-wing
much of it is white supremacists white
nationalist militia sovereign citizen
Patriot group type stuff how is that not
a problem
and then Tucker Carlson says that white
supremacy is a hoax to divide the
country no the white supremacy is what's
dividing the country this is straight-up
irresponsible as much as it is untrue
and I saw a funny comment online white
supremacists are saying that white
supremacists aren't a problem this is
sort of like when corporations say
corporations aren't a problem and we
don't need to regulate they're going to
take care of themselves and super funny
by the way
renewed calls for boycotts of Tucker
Carlson's advertisers and I don't want
to really jump into that topic again
I've talked before about my view on
advertiser boycotts and advertiser
boycotts as a form of speech as a form
of activism that's not the primary topic
today but just by chance I saw that
someone said hey here's a list of
Tucker's remaining advertisers you
should boycott them and I looked at the
list and realized that I've sort of been
boycotting all of those companies for
years anyway because there's just
terrible companies it's like the worst
dentistry chains where I won't even
actually have friends who have told me
how bad they are
really bad dentistry chains I won't name
them supplement companies timeshare
resorts I don't even have to decide
whether I want to boycott Tucker
Carlson's advertisers I've been
boycotting them for years because
they're mostly scammy services and low
reputation companies at this point which
I can't imagine is particularly good for
the bottom line of the Tucker Carlson
show what do you think about what Tucker
is saying white supremacy as a hoax or
fears of white supremacy as a hoax
perpetrated to divide the left to divide
the country rather we've talked about
real hoaxes perpetrated to divide the
country a really good example is the
entire infrastructure that predicates
blaming low wages and class issues and
and issues of income on Hispanic
immigrants when really it's corporations
that have been distracting us so that we
don't notice they are the ones
benefiting from that immigration they
are the ones keeping wages stagnant
that's a real example of a hoax
specifically meant to divide and
distract Americans so that we fight
amongst ourselves instead of realizing
who's really in control that's a real
hoax white supremacy as a hoax I don't
think so
we've got a poll about this on the David
Pakman show Instagram I hope you will
follow it at david pakman show and while
you are there follow me at David Pakman
so two weeks ago I posted pictures of my
tomato plants I am doing urban gardening
here in Boston yesterday I posted a
picture of a rabbit that since I have
built a mesh cage around my tomatoes is
furious the rabbit shows up every day
and just stares at my tomatoes the
rabbit can't get in because of the mesh
cage and the rabbit has been relegated
to eating weeds that are growing in my
yard I put a picture of the rabbit
yesterday on my Instagram page at David
Pakman check it out follow me quick
break we'll be back after this
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blinka it's amazing
it's an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a 15 min
audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudoscience
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink is comm slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n